there you go every couple of weeks we've  been adding flip worthy candidates to  our tweet 16 bracket had been following  that time to add two more from Michigan  say hello to former professional Santa  Claus impersonator I'm not making that  up and current amateur congressman  carried been a bully oh his constituents  they're on the 11th district are very  excited about the prospect of a careless  future but he's got competition from New  Jersey's fifth that happens to be my  hometown where my sister still lives in  congressman Scott Garrett you are not  liked by a lot of people in my all good  I read up on you you're probably going  to win but you are kind of a dick so  let's put these guys up on the bracket  the bracket is starting to fill up so  remember if you want to use our  magnifying glass to burn your pesky ant  of a congressman hit us up on social  media hashtag Flippa district now